my talk of the table is a no-go for
pete davidson oh no way really the
comedian as you probably heard was
scheduled to blast off into space on a
blue origin rocket next week the launch
date has now been pushed back to march
29th and the space company says that
davidson is no longer able to join the
crew you know he's very busy no reason
was given why he can't make the flight
but they do say they will announce a
replacement in the coming days and you
know we're i was thinking tony vlad you
know jeff bezos i'm sure is looking for
um volunteers he consults me on no
business decisions but i do have a
volunteer for him me yeah are you
serious i do tell jeff bezos i want to
go to school no i didn't but here we're
going astral vlad
i do want to go yeah but katie wouldn't
want you to go so no oh wow man yeah
we'll go with that i won't feel hurt
that is your excuse yes my wife doesn't
want me to go but glad i know you really
do i would love to and i can't imagine
what pete davidson can do i love you
pete but i can't imagine what you might
be doing you know what space i think
it's probably business
i'm really kind of busy right now i get
it
he doesn't want to leave staten island
it's a beautiful place we'll we'll send
that on over to jefferson yeah
shout out gail let him know i'm down i'm
dead people that live in staten island
do you think is i know i i visited him
at a place there i know you're a piece
for sunday morning it is truly actually
a beautiful place and there's great bass
fishing off the southern end yes yes